[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein um es gleich am
anfang klar zu sagen das allerletzte was
wir jetzt noch brauchen können wäre ein
neuer krieg in europa schon mit dem wort
krieg sollte man sehr vorsichtig sein
die aber die sich unmittelbar bedroht
fühlen jetzt im moment in der ukraine
bei unseren eu und nato partnern in den
baltischen staaten
sie benutzen das wort mittlerweile ganz
bewusst und das kann uns nicht kalt
lassen
russlands führung fährt panzer und
soldaten auf an der grenze zur ukraine
und sagt nicht was sie damit vorhat in
der ukraine häufen sich cyberattacken
und die usa wollen erfahren haben dass
wladimir putin geheimkommandos
bereithält um einen vorwand zu schaffen
für eine mögliche militäraktion
was tun während militärstrategen und
kreml deutscher zunehmend nervös werden
tritt die bundesregierung
widersprüchlich auf ihr wohl stärkstes
politisches druckmittel gegenüber putin
die neue gaspipeline aus russland
versuchen spd und bundeskanzler jetzt
erstaunlich offen aus der diskussion
herauszuhalten
florian hahn zeigt eine brisante
situation und ein dilemma wer einen
lichtblick sehen will in dieser krise
der muss am ende der woche europäischen
top diplomaten wie hier in brest zu
hören wie sie europäische einigkeit im
angesicht eines möglichen krieges
bejubeln reja ich habe mich gefreut über
ein viel stärkeres gefühl von
gemeinschaft als gewöhnlich rede ich
nehme seit zehn jahren an solchen
treffen teilt so etwas habe ich noch nie
erlebt china messung dieser
an der so beschworenen harmonie gibt es
durchaus zweifel aber dazu gleich auch
heute sind soziale medien voll von
bildern von russischem gerät das
offenbar richtung ukraine verlegt wird
westliche diplomaten glauben immer
weniger an eine bloße drohkulisse nach
insgesamt 17 stunden verhandlungen mit
russischen vertretern in dieser woche
sind positionen dutzendfach abgesteckt
eine bewegung
zu erkennen moskau stellt bedingungen
die der westen für inakzeptabel hält
etwa den ausschluss einer weiteren nato
aus der erweiterung russland wiederum
reagiert darauf mit drohungen manche
blumig formuliert deshalb aber nicht
weniger bedrohlich
unsere geduld ist erschöpft wir sind
sehr geduldig aber wissen sie was man
sagt wie lange russen brauchen um ihre
pferde anzuspannen wir scheren sich
langsam an aber dann ist es zeit zu
reiten
es ist die deutsche außenministerin die
nun die nächsten gespräche führt morgen
in der ukraine am dienstag in moskau
baerbock übt sich in zweckoptimismus
gerade in krisenhaften momenten ist ja
davon gekennzeichnet das ist viel
ausdauer dass es viel geduld braucht
dass es starke nerven braucht starke
nerven reicht das mehr härte das fordern
mehr als 70 osteuropa expertin nun in
einem offenen brief die bundesregierung
dürfe dem aggressiven auftreten
russlands nicht mehr wie bisher
weitgehend tatenlos zusehen es gibt
jetzt wieder den versuch sozusagen nur
rhetorisch und mit symbolischen akten
auf diese große herausforderung
zu reagieren und was wir jetzt im grunde
brauchen ist eine andere sprache die
sich eben durch taten ausdrückt bei den
taten aber endet die europäische
harmonie etwa hier in der ostsee bei der
gaspipeline nord stream 2 die zwar
fertig gebaut aber noch nicht genehmigt
ist während der spd teil der
bundesregierung eifrig an der fixen idee
festhält das projekt sei alles nur nicht
politisch es handelt sich hier im
hinblick auf nord in zwei um ein
privatwirtschaftliches vorhaben zu
erlegen andere diese haltung mit wenigen
worten
nachdem man kann sich doch nicht
vorstellen dass wir einerseits für den
fall der fälle über sanktionen
nachdenken und andererseits so eine
infrastruktur eröffnen
was der russische präsident mit seinen
truppen in der ukraine wirklich vorhat
das weiß am ende wohl nur wladimir putin
selbst
wie der westen auf einen möglichen
einmarsch reagieren würde was der westen
hingegen selbst offenbar noch nicht so
ganz
in den baltischen staaten sind die
erinnerungen an dunkle zeiten des
zweiten weltkriegs nie verblasst die
menschen dort haben auch die ereignisse
vor 30 jahren im kopf als sie ihre
singende revolution und die
wiedererlangung der unabhängigkeit
durchsetzen mussten gegen sowjetische
einheiten
[Musik]
mein vaterland ist meine liebe singen
sie in estland damals wie heute ihre
inoffizielle nationalhymne die in der
sowjetunion verboten worden
[Musik]
estland lettland und litauen sind anders
als die ukraine längst mitglieder der
nato und mitglieder der europäischen
union
das darf man nicht vergessen
general a d richard r us war
oberbefehlshaber der armee von estland
und ist jetzt als abgeordneter für die
konservative volksparteien familie im
europaparlament hat hessischen guten
abend nach tallinn guten abend können
sie uns das mal beschreiben wie die
menschen in erst land die situation
jetzt im moment empfinden
natürlich mit großer sorge
man muss die forderung der russlands
glauben
wir haben es schwierigkeiten das zu
glauben im politik in europa aber
russland hat schon seit 2007 immer
wieder gesagt dass die gerne die
sicherheits
ordnung in europa um
stadtgestaltung wollen und dass die
theoretisch oder zum jahr
1999 kommen wollen
und das macht uns in island aber auch in
den ganzen
osteuropäische raum große sorgen sie
sprechen jetzt von putins aktionen als
einem final wake up call
haben sie den eindruck europa ist wach
gerüttelt
ja ich glaube dass das die ersten becker
zugeschlagen worden sind zum beispiel
georgien aber auch an lektionen von
cream und ukraine 2014 wir haben zwar
verstanden dass etwas falsch ist und
gesehen dass russland gerne bereit ist
auch militärische gewalt einzusetzen und
die politische ziele zu erreichen aber
so richtig begriffen haben wir es nicht
dass russland noch mehr der litauische
oberbefehlshaber der armee sagt seit
1945 sei europa nicht mehr so nah an
einem krieg gewesen ein krieg gegen
baltische staaten
wäre das nicht ein wahnsinn auch für
putin
das ist wahnsinn genau so wahnsinnig
haben leute kraft ist das protein kokain
an greift also und wenn man sagt ob das
krieg und ich würd sagen in ukraine ist
krieg jeden tag und leute sterben jeden
tag
wir befürchten nicht dass es jetzt
irgendwie sich nach baltikum schlägt
weil wir mitglieder der nato und
europäische union sind aber um das
sicherzustellen dass hier nichts
passiert dann müssen wir einigkeit
zeigen wir müssen im nato europäischen
union zeigen dass wir auch meinen was
wir sagen und das ist bis heute ganz gut
gelungen denke ich was heißt denn meinen
was wir sagen ganz konkret ich frag sie
jetzt mal auf deutschland bezogen auf
die deutsche bundesregierung was
erwarten sie vom bundeskanzler scholz
er eigentlich erwarte ich ein aktives
deutschland ein selbstbewusstes
deutschland das größte land in europa
das gerne uns für kinder in diesen
dialog mit russen aber nicht nur sondern
auch bereit ist wenn nötig abschreckung
und auch militärische mittel zu nutzen
wenn es dazu kommt aber wir müssen
zeigen dass sie bereit sind zu halten
ökonomisch aber auch militärisch was
heißt denn wenn ich wieder unterbrechen
darf er terrace militärische mittel
sollte deutschland nutzen wenn es dazu
kommt was meinen sie damit ein einsatz
der bundeswehr ein ganzes der bundeswehr
in litauen ist schon da und das heißt
der stärkung der
osteuropäischen länder eben wenn sie
etwas
wenn die ansprüche da sind denke ich
schon ist möglich aber aus sicht noch
sehr wichtiger finde dass deutschland
dafür er steht das nicht große länder
über die köpfe der kleineren
europa verteilen sondern dass wir immer
abstimmen miteinander sprechen und
eigentlich zusammen handeln das ist für
uns für kleine länder im baltikum sehr
wichtig jetzt liegt noch diese pipeline
auf dem tisch nord stream 2 ist wieder
in aller munde da sagt jetzt die
bundesregierung auch der bundeskanzler
das ist ein privatwirtschaftliches
projekt alles und politisch sagt olaf
scholz das klingt jetzt überhaupt nicht
so als sei das für ihn teil von
möglichen sanktionen gegen russland was
sagen sie dazu
prinzipiell sind die gasrechnungen
leute in deutschland denke ich auch aber
in estland und ideal sehen sehen sie das
russland dieses dieses gas mittel nutzt
wie eine
wie ein
[Musik]
mittel um etwas zu erreichen und und
gaspreise sind sehr hoch weil ostern das
einfach gas zugedreht hat das
sich von einem von russischem gas
abhängig zu machen ist nicht politisch
logisch und dürfen deshalb sind auch die
nordsee 92 sehr schlecht und die sind
noch dafür sehr schlecht dass auch
ukraine
umgangen wird sagte general richard r us
ehemals oberbefehlshaber der estischen
armee ich danke ihnen für das gespräch
nach tallinn
vielen dank
wenn sie gesund sie auch
gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
kurz vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
china will in knapp drei wochen die
jugend der welt empfangen zu den
olympischen winterspielen und china
schottet sich ab der internationale
flugverkehr nach china ist im vergleich
zu vor der pandemie um 98 prozent
eingebrochen ein paar infektionsfälle
reichen damit ganze millionenstädte
abgeriegelt werden die hauptstadt soll
eine null cobit festung sein virus frei
aber jetzt hat omikron auch peking
erreicht chinas behörden wissen alles
über den ersten omikron fall wo sie
wohnt und arbeitet welche restaurants
und u-bahnen sie nutzte und auch welche
öffentlichen toiletten aber wie sie sich
anstecken konnte das wissen sie nicht
aus peking christiane hoffmann
strikt abgeschirmt sind die ersten gut
1000 olympia teilnehmer als techniker in
peking angekommen sie wohnen in hotels
hinter grünen zonen dürfen nur in
speziellen bussen zu den olympia orten
fahren china hofft so dass corona virus
von seinen bürgern fernzuhalten
doch schon vor den olympia teilnehmern
hatte es omikron ins land geschafft und
gestern wurde auch in peking der erste
fall bestätigt wir haben 2004 130
menschen im wohnviertel und am
arbeitsplatz der frau getestet 15 enge
kontakte sind in quarantäne
damit muss sich die regierung
eingestehen dass ihre 0 kowitz strategie
wankt präsident hat corona freie spiele
versprochen stattdessen läuft eine neue
infektionswelle durchs land wenn auch
auf niedrigem niveau
nacheinander haben sie in dieser woche
fälle in immer mehr städten bestätigt
und immer häufiger ist es omikron
mit massentests von millionen von
menschen und lockt downs kämpft china
nun darum seine 0 kowitz strategie über
die olympischen spiele zu retten in
pekings nachbarstadt dienten wurden mehr
als 200 fälle bestätigt die stadt in
time lockdown versetzt busse und züge
nach peking gestoppt die hauptstadt wird
mehr und mehr abgeschottet das zeigt wie
nervös die regierung ist dass das virus
außer kontrolle geraten und das
gesundheitssystem an seine grenzen
bringen könnte denn es ist nicht klar
wie gut der chinesische impfstoff gegen
omikron wirkt schon bei den ersten
virusvarianten war die wirkung niedriger
als bei den neuen westlichen m rna
impfstoffen nur alleine die im
aktivierten wechsel impfstoffe werden
wahrscheinlich gegen das omikron virus
ich werde wahnsinnig viel ausrichten
können und da ist dann schon die gefahr
dass diese janukowitsch politik die
china verfolgt einfach funktioniert
und noch ein ereignis wirft dunkle
schatten voraus parallel zu den
winterspielen feiert china sein neues
jahr mit dem frühlingsfest zum
wichtigsten familienfest werden gut eine
milliarde reisen innerhalb chinas
erwartet die regierung hat zwar noch
striktere kontrollen angekündigt durch
omikron könnte es dennoch ein super
special event werden
ja eine milliarde reisen wir bleiben bei
corona kommen nach europa zurück und
hanna du hast die nachrichtenübersicht
da schauen wir in eines unserer
nachbarländer
während in deutschland nämlich noch über
eine corona impfpflicht diskutiert wird
hat österreichs regierung bereits am
mittag einen gesetzentwurf dazu
vorgestellt die impfpflicht für
erwachsene ab 18 jahren soll anfang
februar in kraft treten wer sich nicht
daran hält für den kann es teuer werden
aber mit der mertz kontrolliert unter
anderem die polizei und impfverweigerer
müssen mit strafen von bis zu 3600 euro
rechnen ausnahmen gelten für schwangere
und für menschen die sich aus
medizinischen gründen nicht impfen
lassen können das parlament wird am
donnerstag über das gesetz abstimmen
der britische premier johnson steht
weiter unter druck wegen zahlreicher
partys in der downing street mitten im
corona lockdown nun hat sich der
generalsekretär der konservativen partei
darin hinter den premier gestellt
johnston werde gegen diese kultur am
regierungssitz vorgehen sagte er laut
einem bericht der sunday times erwägt
der britische premier offenbar wegen der
party affäre mehrere engere mitarbeiter
zu entlassen
nach dem ausbruch eines
unterwasservulkans vor dem
südpazifischen tonga ist das ausmaß der
zerstörung weiter unklar die gewaltige
explosion hatte gestern selbst in peru
für überschwemmungen gesorgt auch an der
us-westküste kam wellen an tongas
hauptstadt sei erheblich getroffen
worden sagte unterdessen die
neuseeländische premier ministerin die
kommunikationsverbindungen sei gestört
offizielle berichte über tote und
verletzte gebe es noch nicht
spezialkräfte der us polizei haben im
texanischen collie will eine
mehrstündige geiselnahme in einer
synagoge beendet präsident biden sprach
von einem terrorakt ein bewaffneter
hatte über mehrere stunden vier menschen
festgehalten darunter den rabbiner wie
die behörden mitteilten kamen alle
geiseln unverletzt frei der angreifer
ersten medienberichten zufolge ein brite
starb er hatte zuvor offenbar versucht
eine verurteilte pakistanische
terroristen freizupressen
der cdu-chef heißt armin laschet und
zwar noch bis kommenden samstag dann ist
parteitag und der sieger der
mitgliederbefragung wird offiziell
übernehmen es ist also eine woche in der
sich friedrich merz jetzt noch mal
sammeln kann und umsehen er wird viele
baustellen entdecken und auch ein
interner machtkampf könnte ins haus
stehen obwohl die union jetzt alles
mögliche braucht aber keinen neuen
führungsstreit mathis feldhoff über eine
partei mit neuem chef und alten
problemen
es ist die erfüllung eines traums aber
auch die verarbeitung eines traumas in
wenigen tagen wird friedrich merz zum
neuen chef der cdu gewählt der
konservative hoffnungsträger steht vor
jeder menge herausforderungen
[Musik]
unbestritten ist merz der chef der
partei doch greift er auch nach dem
parlamentarischen arm nach der führung
in der fraktion stößt der ralph
brinkhaus vom thron wie es einst angela
merkel mit ihm tat um olaf scholz paroli
zu bieten seine andeutungen sprechen für
neuen streit das kein geheimnis das habe
ich immer wieder gesagt dass ich sowohl
für die regierung es für richtig halte
das parteivorsitz und kanzleramt in
einer hand sind als auch für die
opposition das parteivorsitz und
fraktionsvorsitz in einer hand sind
ralph brinkhaus kämpft um seinen job
sein größter verbündeter ist die zeit
liegen doch im frühjahr diverse
landtagswahlen und so erinnert man in
der fraktion märz gerne an die jüngste
vergangenheit und die wahlniederlage
gerade die erfahrungen aus dem letzten
jahr die zeigen uns doch eindrücklich
dass wir die bewältigen mit einem hohen
maß an geschlossenheit deswegen bin ich
davon überzeugt beide sind sich auch
ihrer verantwortung bewusst und werden
zur richtigen zeit auch die richtige
lösung und die richtige aufstellung für
uns als partei und fraktion finden
er ist nur einfaches parteimitglied und
dennoch wird hans georg maßen die cdu
immer wieder auf zuletzt mit thesen aus
dem querdenker milieu
erst spät hat die parteispitze reagiert
und sich gegen maßen positioniert
wir distanzieren uns klar von den
inhalten die er in sozialen netzwerken
geteilt hat und wir weisen sie aufs
schärfste zurück jetzt tobt der streit
um die konsequenzen der parteiausschluss
des querulanten steht im raum ein
totschweigen ist glaube ich nicht
möglich ich habe da keinen bock mehr
drauf und insofern fand ich es ganz
wichtig wenn der nächste bundesvorstand
diesbezüglich auch ein klares zeichen
setzt
über ein jahrzehnt hat die cdu ihren
standort quasi an jede wand geschrieben
die mitte da hat man sich gesehen unter
angela merkel wie unter kramp
karrenbauer
friedrich merz stellt das jetzt in frage
diese mitte ist jedenfalls kein sich
selbst erklärende raum mehr schreibt er
anfang januar in seiner märz nähe
driftet die partei jetzt ins
wirtschaftsfreundliche und konservative
die cdu sozialpolitiker warnen märz die
sogenannte mitte preiszugeben nicht nur
als slogan hat die cdu eine antenne für
die lebenswirklichkeit von millionen von
menschen in diesem land von
alleinerziehenden jungen familien von
geringverdienern von menschen mit einer
kleinen rente und das müssen wir wieder
dort niemand
friedrich merz muss sich neu erfinden
der mann der oft gespalten hat muss nun
zusammenführen der immer einzelgänger
war muss ein team bilden der sich immer
für den besten hielt muss andere glänzen
lassen das sind vielleicht die größten
baustellen des neuen cdu vorsitzenden
soll jetzt der sonntags sport hier in
der sendung hanna du hast den überblick
wir starten mit handball das dhb team
traf am abend im zweiten vorrundenspiel
der europameisterschaft auf österreich
und konnte den zweiten sieg in folge
nach hause holen das team von alfred
gislason gewann mit 34 zu 29 bester
werfer der deutschen mannschaft wurde
mit neun treffern timo kastl -ing am
dienstag trifft das dhb team dann auf
polen in
der fußball bundesliga trafen heute der
fc augsburg und eintracht frankfurt
aufeinander eins zu eins lautete das
endergebnis im zweiten spiel trennten
sich schlusslicht greuther fürth und der
tabellenvorletzte aus bielefeld
ebenfalls unentschieden mit 2 zu 2
francesco friedrich hat im letzten
weltcup rennen der saison seinen ersten
niederlage verkraften müssen im
viererbob belegte er den zweiten platz
den gesamtweltcup in der königsklasse
hatte er sich schon vor einer woche in
winterberg sich hat die frauen zeigten
knapp drei wochen vor den winterspielen
olympia bestform bei der bob
europameisterschaft in st moritz
feierten die deutschen pilotinnen einen
dreifach erfolg im kajak gewann im
zweier bob vor olympiasiegerin maria
maria manca und laura nolte
und die nummer eins der tennis
weltrangliste ist raus bei den
australian open und zwar bevor die
überhaupt begonnen haben sein gegner
stand nicht auf dem platz es ist der
australische
einwanderungsminister der am ende
radikal die taktik gewechselt hatte es
ging den behörden plötzlich nicht mehr
um novak djokovic fragwürdigen umgang
mit testergebnissen und
einreisebestimmungen
sondern um ein zeichen djokovic sei zu
einer ikone der impfgegner geworden und
damit zu einer gefahr für die
öffentliche ordnung
die für einen rechtsstaat ausgesprochen
merkwürdige begründung dürfte australien
noch länger beschäftigen
klar ist in seiner heimat serbien ist
djokovic tatsächlich eine ikone geworden
weit über den sport hinaus auch bei
denen die mit ihm knallharte politik
machen wollen britta hilpert berichtet
novak djokovic verlässt australien hat
dem visum streit verloren es ist ein
bild das sein umfeld offensichtlich gar
nicht mag ich bin extrem enttäuscht dass
djokovic schriftlich wissen aber ich
respektiere das gerichtsurteil
er deutet an dass er später vielleicht
mehr sagt die serbischen fans in
melbourne erwarten dass man auch bei
seiner abreise heute wieder
demonstrationen denn es geht nicht nur
um einen sportler meinen sie hier
international es geht nicht nur um die
nummer 1 im tennis er ist auch eine art
botschafter für serbien
es ist unfair dass sie ihn nicht spielen
lassen nur weil er nicht geimpft ist
doch es geht um mehr djokovic machte
falsche angaben bei der einreise unter
anderem zu aufenthaltsorten der
australische minister widerrief das
visum wohl auch weil der eigene regiere
corona kurs sonst unglaubwürdig wirkt
sport ist politik das gilt auch für
serbien hier ist djokovic status
überlebensgroß und die regierung nutzt
das für sich sie stilisiert das vorgehen
gegen einen sportler zum angriff auf
sein heimatland denn das vereint die
nation möglichst hinter seinem
präsidenten der bald wieder gewählt
werden will
[Musik]
medien geschenk und hexenjagd nennt das
der serbische präsident rutsche gegen
eine person gegen ein land der nowak
wollen sie zeigen wie die weltordnung
funktioniert
geburtstag doch dass der star positiv
getestet für die sportzeitung l'équipe
ein fotoshooting macht und sogar kinder
trifft ohne maske auch in serbien hat
man das bemerkt die öffentliche empörung
in belgrad wird deshalb heute abgeflaut
bin auch trotz hier ehrensache ist ja
und trotzt allen widrigkeiten das ist
unser nationalcharakter er wird dadurch
nur stärken
es war seine entscheidung sich nicht
impfen zu lassen er muss die folgen
tragen aber es tut mir leid
nur so nennen ihn serben nur du bist der
stolz serbiens leuchtet es heute abend
in belgrad djokovic selbst wird es kaum
sehen ersucht ruhe heißt es fern der
heimat denn serbien hatte die wohl kaum
wie immer im sport wo verlierer sind
gibt es auch gewinner aktuell heißt der
salvatore caruso nummer 150 der
weltrangliste
er hatte die quali nicht geschafft und
darf jetzt doch dabei sein anstelle des
champions ein lucky looser
dara hassanzadeh nimmt uns jetzt mit in
die kommende woche der heute journal
ausblick
[Musik]
am dienstag zwei tage vor dem jahrestag
wird präsident steinmeier der
wannsee-konferenz gedenken am 20 januar
1942 tagten die nationalsozialisten um
die deportation und tötung der gesamten
jüdischen bevölkerung zu koordinieren
der damalige tagungsort ist heute eine
holocaust gedenkstätte
am mittwoch wird der französische
präsident makro eine rede vor dem eu
parlament halten und die schwerpunkte
der französischen ratspräsidentschaft
skizzieren die europäische
zusammenarbeit solle sich zu einer
europäischen souveränität
weiterentwickeln sechs monate wird makro
für die weichenstellung haben
am donnerstag wird ein juristisches
gutachten zu sexuellen missbrauch an
minderjährigen und erwachsenen
schutzbefohlenen im erzbistum münchen
freising veröffentlicht der
untersuchungszeitraum erstreckt sich von
1945 bis 2009 10 in dieser zeit war
sowohl kardinal marx wie der spätere
papst benedikt als bischof
verantwortlich für diese diözese
und jetzt noch der blick auf die
ziemlich trüben wetteraussichten
über den osten und südosten zieht morgen
regen in den bergen schnee danach gibt
es sonne dazu weht ein starker anfangs
auch noch stürmischer nordwestwind sonst
bleibt es bei dichten wolken trocken die
temperatur steigt auf 2 bis 9 grad am
dienstag bleibt es trocken am mittwoch
gibt es regen und wind im nordosten am
donnerstag in der mitte und im süden die
temperatur verändert sich dabei kaum
ja nicht nur die temperatur verändert
sich kaum auch ihr heute journal kommt
morgen verlässlich um 21 uhr 45 dann mit
den kolleginnen bettina schausten und
gundula gause und wir beide schon zu
schauen zu und wir empfehlen ihnen
außerdem noch die heute express um 0.25
mit sarah bilder vom gesagten
heute-journal thiemann sie einen sehr
angenehmen abend
[Musik]